is America's security threatened by Tick
Tock its CEO arrived at Congress
prepared to reassure lawmakers the U.S
and his platform's 150 million users
there could trust them there are many
misconceptions about our company and I'm
very proud to come here and represent
them and all our users here in this
country
but the committee's Mind seemed made up
to the American people watching today
hear this Tick Tock is a weapon by the
Chinese Communist party to spy on you
manipulate what you see and exploit for
future Generations Mr Chu tried to
dismiss any connection between tick
tock's parent company bite dance and the
Chinese Communist Party a congressman
since I've been CEO of this company I
have not had any discussions with
Chinese government officials
and answer criticism of how Tick-Tock
fails to protect young users from
harmful content
the potential security privacy content
manipulation concerns raised about tech
talk are really not unique to us the
same issues to apply to other companies
Mr Chu tried to argue Tick-Tock was
promising to go further than any social
media company to protect users data and
safety but the committee weren't buying
it
you damn well know that you cannot
protect the data and security of this
committee or the 150 million users of
your app because it is an extension of
the CCP and with that I yield back can I
respond sure
no we're gonna move on
even critics of tick tock have found it
hard to watch this is something that
they they can't win they can't placate
those really sort of angry anti-china
Hawks they can't placate those who are
kind of uh letting go of 20 years of
anger at Big Tech and the realization
that we let these companies writ large
get too big and uh couldn't control them
and anger on both sides is is so strong
that there's no reasoned argument taking
place in this hearing as the grilling
continued in DC parliament in London
announced the app would be blocked from
Wi-Fi on its estate
oh bans on Tick Tock a sensible step as
diplomatic relations deteriorate or an
erosion of freedoms more commonly seen
in States like China Tom Clark Sky News